Speaker 1: There was endless, endless. There were
endless instances yesterday during the first day
of questions being asked of Joe Biden's Supreme
Court nominee, Judge Katagiri Brown Jackson.
Examples of bizarre, inappropriate and
cartoonishly odd questions asked of her.
And I'm going to show you some of them now
before we look at the first one in the first
one is going to be Lindsey Graham asking the
judge to rate her level of religiosity. I think
it's important to understand that in some general
sense, these hearings are basically a sideshow.
99 percent of the time every senator has
already decided how they're going to vote on
the nomination. They've already they already know
the answers to the questions that they're asking,
and typically you will see senators from
the party that nominated the candidate,
the nominee. Just throw what
we call throwing bouquets at
each other. Praise. Talk to us about how
great your parents are. Stuff like that.
And then those in the opposite party will ask
antagonistic questions. Now there are substantive,
antagonistic questions. An example would be
if I had to say who was the best Republican
yesterday in terms of asking questions. It was
Ben Sasse. They were respectful questions. That
seemed material to the role of being a Supreme
Court justice. Lindsey Graham, Marsha Blackburn,
Ted Cruz an absolute and total joke. Let's start
with the first clip. Here is Lindsey Graham asking
What religion are you and how religious are you?
Speaker 2: What faith are you, by the way?
Speaker 3: Senator, I am Protestant.
Speaker 2: Hmm. OK, non-denominational day.
Could you fairly judge a Catholic? Senator, I
have a record of I'm going to be judging every
way you can. I'm just and by the way,
Speaker 1: every Republican senator
other than Ben Sasse relentlessly
interrupting Judge Jackson relentlessly
Speaker 2: in this question, because
how important is your faith to?
Speaker 3: Senator, personally, my faith is very
important. But as you know, there's no religious
test in the Constitution under under Article six.
Speaker 1: How important is your faith? You later
asking her to rate her religiosity from one to
10? It's 20, 22 guys, it is 20, 22, and Lindsey
Graham is asking this question during a Supreme
Court hearing. Ted Cruz making a mockery of the
entire hearing by asking about racist babies.
Speaker 2: Do you agree with this book that is
being taught with kids that the babies are racist?
Speaker 3: Senator.
Speaker 1: The pause is real.
Speaker 3:
I do not believe that any child should be made to
feel as though they are racist or though they are.
Not valued or though they are less than that,
they are victims, that they are oppressors,
I don't. Believe in any of that.
Speaker 1: Now, importantly,
these are not issues on which a Supreme Court
justice normally has to have an opinion. I mean,
it is not really for a lawyer or judge
to determine whether babies are racist.
It's not a particular topic I've thought about
too much, but if I wanted an answer to it,
I wouldn't go to a Supreme Court justice. Marsha
Blackburn may be the most weaponized of all of
the Republican senators on the Judiciary Committee
asks Are there differences between men and women
again? Supreme Court Justice, what
Speaker 3: do you agree with Justice Ginsburg
that there are physical differences
between men and women that are enduring?
Senator. Respectfully, I am not familiar
with that particular quote or case,
so it's hard for me to comment as to why.
Speaker 1: Now that was another theme where
Republican senators would say, Judge Jackson,
are you familiar with this book? And then this
article about the book? No, I've never read
the book and I've never read the article.
OK, which of the two do you agree with
the entire day? Here's one more clip of
Marsha Blackburn asking Can you define woman?
Speaker 3: And can you provide a definition
for the word woman? Can I provide a
definition? Yeah. I can't you can't.
Not a case contact. I'm not in biology
of the word woman is so unclear and
controversial that you can't give me a definition.
Speaker 1: Now this is this this rings very hits
close to home for me because when I
was on the Jesse Lee Peterson show
out in California a couple of years ago,
he asked me to define man. He said, What
is a man? And I said, I do politics. I don't.
I don't do definitions. I know this isn't the
I'm not the dictionary. And it was like this
all day. Now, interestingly, despite all of
the qualifications of Judge Jackson last night,
Tucker Carlson on Fox News was still wondering
Where are Judge Jackson's LSAT scores legal minds?
Speaker 2: One way to know one indication would
be her LSAT scores. The LSAT is not a knowledge
test. It measures logic and reasoning ability,
and no one doubts. It's an accurate
measure of those things which predict
legal skills. And that's why top law firms
law schools have long used that test. So
how did Kentucky Brown Jackson do in the outset?
Speaker 1: And by the way, Ken Taji, guys, I mean,
listen. For years, it's not Kamala. It's Kamilla,
Kamala, Kamala Harris, et cetera, et cetera. And
now in the last day, I've heard from these right
wingers Ken Taji, which is not her name, katana
and a whole bunch of others. At what point do
we wonder whether they're doing it on purpose?
And I don't know the answer. So Tucker remains
concerned about the LSAT scores humiliation.
Complete and total humiliation from these right
wingers, and by every sensible estimation,
Judge Jackson will have no problem getting
on the court. Let me know your thoughts. Find
me on Twitter at De Packman. The David
Pakman Show is funded and made possible
by you, and I would love for you to sign up
and support the program at join Packman Gqom.